comment poursuivre le dialogue alors que
les états unis répondent toujours par
des menaces de sanctions une désescalade
détention est elle toujours possible qui
saura enfin apaiser les choses c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
est avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter à france sur ce
plateau bons soient régis avec nous
aussi sur ce plateau charles pratta
orateurs cellule de riposte de valérie
pécresse candidate en tant que les
républicains la présidentielle 2022
bonsoir avec nous françois pupponi
député modem du val d'oise qui va nous
accompagner par skype bonsoir françois
pupponi merci d'être là régis le sommier
on en a beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines toutes ces négociations tous
les jours et là on voit que c'est le
point mort chacun se rejette la faute
on a du mal à voir comment on va se se
sortir de cette situation et
l'inquiétude grandit en tout cas
l'inquiétude disons qu'elle est elle est
la tension est permanente 1 on voit se
rendre de deux des changes en fait entre
les russes et des américains à la
tribune de l'onu on a en effet cette
tension permanente
on ne peut le dire c'est vrai que la
presse américaine là dessus et assez
incisive et même parfois va au delà de
comme en 2d de ceux des déclarations du
gouvernement il ya peu d'apaisement dans
cette crise il ya peu de com en revanche
une multitude de manières d'exacerber
les choses et c'est vrai que quand les
américains disent il y a de plus en plus
de troupes russes et russes disent il y
a d'où vous tenez ces chiffres etc quand
on regarde quand même la carte de
l'ukraine on voit le positionnement des
bases russes autour de l'ukraine c'est
qu'il ya quand même un nombre
considérable d'armement de base qui
existe autour du pays et voilà et ça il
faut le reconnaître maintenant il ya eu
aussi une comment une comment une
livraison il ya des livraisons
permanente d'armes aux ukrainiens de la
part des occidentaux ils n'en font pas
mystère en les missiles javelin ya eu
plusieurs reportages sur eux qui ont
déjà été livrés aux troupes
l'ukrainienne sur le feront également
des drones mombert aktar qui sont les
drones qui ont été arrêtés parce qu'ils
sont produits par les turcs et qui ont
été largement testé au karabagh l'année
dernière c'est mais ces armes là elles
sont elles ont été livrés et il ya eu
une augmentation et les américains dans
font pas mystère donc de part et d'autre
il y a une manière de dire on est
sérieux on montre les muscles ensuite
laissons place à la diplomatie parce
qu'à chaque fois c'est ce qui se passe
mais de semaine en semaine la situation
d'hier est pourri d'une certaine façon
il va falloir trouver une solution le
risque dans ce type de co2 de 2 de
tension extrême c'est qu'une un incident
puisse mettre le feu aux poudres ou
comment une initiative ou quelque chose
qui pourrait se passer d'ailleurs dans
l'est de l'ukraine avec notamment les
des deux républiques donc sécessionniste
qui pour il pourrait y avoir à ce moment
là où une provocation de part et d'autre
et qui pourraient éventuellement
conduire à une guerre d'où le problème
est hélas la l2 de garder la main
diplomatiquement le plus longtemps
possible et d'essayer de trouver une
solution rapidement justement on va la
voir un cette carte parce qu'elle est
elle est riche en enseignements
voilà on voit que c'est de chaque côté
qu'il y a des troupes
peut-être que ça n'apparaît pas toujours
dans l'esprit effectivement de de chacun
il ya des troupes du côté ouest
évidemment avec l'otan en estonie
lituanie pologne jusqu'à la turquie
évidemment des troupes russes de l'autre
côté
près de la frontière russe cette fois-ci
charles parce qu'on vous voyez cette
carte effectivement à la lumière de ce
que nous dit régis il suffit d'une
étincelle est ce que vous vous êtes
inquiet aujourd'hui où finalement chacun
montre ses muscles pour au final trouver
peut-être un terrain d'entente alors
fait on ne peut qu'être inquiet bush
cheney un certain nombre de fois en
ukraine
quand vous discutez avec les ukrainiens
à la population
les gens sont évidemment inquiets et
surtout ne sont pas dans l'optique de se
laisser faire dakhla les ukrainiens
s'ils sont agressés ils vont se défendre
évidemment à mes skis et ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est cette espèce de montée
des tensions
avec de l'armement de part et d'autre
effectivement si ça bah si à un moment
donné il ya eu une étincelle c'est comme
ça que les guerres se déclenche souvent
c'est parce que il ya une il ya un
incident et puis derrière vous avez un
enchaînement qui fait que l'on bascule
sur un affrontement armé d'autres
intensité ah ah bon c'est absolument ce
qu'il faut éviter c'est ce que dadis est
valérie pécresse il faut geler la
situation et il s'agit d'avoir une
vision équilibrée c'est la vision
gaullienne des choses ou gaullistes des
choses c'est une vision équilibrée
évidemment garantir l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine les hors de
question à de laisser l'ukraine se faire
envahir par la russie et de l'autre côté
il faut aussi être capable d'entendre ce
que disent les russes d'entendre ce que
dit vladimir poutine d'entendre la
position de la russie qui elle même a
des demandes par rapport à sa propre
sécurité par rapport notamment à
l'extension éventuelle de l'otan et
c'est ce qu'a encore à expliquer a très
justement valérie pécresse ya quelques
jours
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan n'est
objectivement pas quelque chose qui
devrait être une des priorités des
années à venir dans une europe qui veut
construire sa sécurité et dans une
europe apaisée ce n'est vraiment pas là
le chemin qu'il faudrait prendre donc on
est sur des systèmes où il faut apaiser
les choses
évidemment s'il ya une problématique
militaire défendre l'ukraine avec elle
les mesures adaptées des sanctions
éventuelles etc mais surtout retrouver
le dialogue et la france a une voix
particulière les relations de la france
et de la russie depuis des siècles des
siècles ce sont des relations très
particulières tout comme la france et
des états unis ont une relation
particulière
la france est à l'origine la création
des états unis nous sommes des alliés
indéfectibles des états unis nous sommes
les amis des etats-unis mais nous ne
devons pas être les vassaux des états
unis et de la même manière avec la
russie ça fait des siècles que ça dure
nous avons une histoire culturelle une
histoire politique commune avec beaucoup
de choses qui ont été faites dans le
passé
justement la place d'emmanuel macro
aujourd'hui mais poursuivons sur cette
situation françois pupponi
officiellement à la crise a débuté en
avril dernier quand la russie a
concentré ses forces militaires autour
de l'ukraine mais en fait ça fait
plusieurs années que l'otan avance vers
l'est avec notamment s'en souvient
l'arrivée de l'estonien en 2004 à ce que
selon vous il est légitime ou illégitime
aujourd'hui que le kremlin affirme ne
pas avoir été entendu sur ses demandes
de garanties de sécurité
est ce qu on entend cette voie rue c est
ce qu elle est légitime selon vous à la
lumière de cette carte qu'on vient de
voir tout à l'heure en tout cas vu de
moscou et des légitimes il y avait des
mêmes des accords qui ont été signés
avec les engagements qui avaient été
pris et effectivement depuis un certain
temps on voit l'otan progresser sur ce
qu'on appelle la zone d'influencé de la
russie est effectivement n'oublions pas
tout à l'heure il n'y a fait référence
au conflit du haut karabagh l'année
dernière ces lasers radiant aidé par la
turquie avec du matériel de l'otan des
awacs de l'otan en particulier qui sont
rentrés au karabagh qui sont même
rentrés les aliments d'arménie il a
fallu que ça soit les russes qui à un
moment disent stop et arrêtent que les
troupes azéries après la prise de sushis
donc on voit bien que dans cette partie
du monde des choses sont en train de
bouger et qu'à un moment les russes
disent stop ça suffit je pense qu'il
faut les entendre après ça se discute
faut négocier mais effectivement la
tension est plus que palpable et en tout
cas je pense que petit dit à un moment
on
n'acceptera plus qu'on aille plus loin
celui sur toute l'ukraine a depuis
longtemps été le sujet et
des lieux de conflits et de
revendications donc là il faut
l'entendre je pense qu'effectivement
vous êtes élu aussi que la france et
l'europe ont leur rôle à jouer
ça se passe à notre porte si bien
entendu des américains qui sont la
manoeuvre et 15 mai ça se passe à notre
porte comme ceux qui comme le conflit du
haut karabakh se passe à notre porte et
on voit très bien que 6e dérape dans
cette partie du monde c'est l'europe qui
est en première ligne donc bien entendu
nous avons repris les réunions
organisées par plusieurs actions ne font
que confirmer que l'europe 1 et la
france ont bien entendu un rôle à jouer
ils vont apporter à l'instant les états
unis qui se disent prêts quoi qu'il
arrive un prévient baydan vous dites la
france et l'europe ont un rôle à jouer
justement pour le chef de la diplomatie
française jean yves le drian la voie du
dialogue est toujours privilégiée en
europe vous propose de l'écouter
nous sommes déterminés à mener ce
dialogue jusqu'au bout pour mettre le
président poutine devant ses
responsabilités et l'opportunité de
discuter d'un nouvel ordre de sécurité
et de stabilité en europe toute atteinte
nouvelle à l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine aura des conséquences massive
on ne peut pas être plus clair ma
collègue allemande a dit pas un pas de
plus je fais mienne cette expression
l'opportunité de discuter d'un nouvel
ordre de sécurité de stabilité en europe
c'est tout l'enjeu régis le sommier de
ces négociations est ce qu'il pourrait
être l'occasion justement de sortir un
nouvel ordre on sait que les murs
poutine et emmanuel macron évoqué par
téléphone les garanties de sécurité de
moscou qu'est-ce qui pourrait accoucher
de cette forme de négociation si ça se
produit en tout cas ce sera un succès à
mettre au crédit des manuels macron dont
la politique internationale a été
relativement pauvre en succès et en plus
en ce moment est en train de se
détériorer en afrique avec ce qui se
passe au mali si macron arrive à
influencer poutine en tout cas à ce
qu'il y ait un vrai dialogue entre
l'europe et les et la russie cette fois
ci je dirais que les états unis les
etats unis sont en première ligne on a
vu que les états unis ont ont consulté
leurs alliés ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
dans les crises précédentes un
afghanistan je reviens pas sur la sphère
des sous marins australiens mais les
états unis avaient perdu l'habitude
justement là ils ont essayé justement de
manier la nuit une initiative de la part
d' emmanuel macron qui me paraît
intéressante différente du suivisme
habituel maintenant pourra-t-elle
débouchés parce que encore faudrait-il
que
la zone europe parlent d'une même voix
on a vu que dans cette crise aussi a eu
des des dissonances notamment de la part
des allemands parce que ils sont
directement concernés à cause de
l'approvisionnement du but du gaz russe
les anglais jouent leur rôle mais ils ne
sont plus dans l'europe mais jouent leur
rôle d'allié un d'effectifs fidèle des
états unis même en étant en faisant de
la surenchère on voit ce que boris
johnson essaye de faire en ce moment qui
est peut-être aussi de sauver sa place à
cause de ces petits problèmes au 10
downing street mais en tout cas il ya
une fidélité renouvelées voilà de la
part des anglais et est donc il ya
diverses voit maintenant la voilà moi je
pense que dante dans cette initiative
je dis pas que c'est vrai qu'on qui va
sauver l'ukraine mais en tout cas il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant
charles passe justement on l'a vu un du
côté de la france et on manie la fermeté
et le dialogue qu'est ce qui ferait la
différence je vais me pécresse si votre
candidat c'était aujourd'hui au pouvoir
comment elles géraient ce dossier
ukrainien différemment de maquereaux je
pense que déjà nous avons un problème de
position de négociation certes la france
aurait une capacité de négociation qui
serait bien meilleur si par exemple elle
avait conservé son indépendance
énergétique tels vous venez de le citer
on a le problème de l'approvisionnement
en gaz russe demain vous prenez des
sanctions économiques supplémentaires
contre la russie vous l'empêchez de
payer en dollars et c'est à la russie
peut fermer le robinet du gaz alors là
vous avez vous retrouvé dans une
situation en europe catastrophique avec
une inflation des coûts de l'énergie qui
vont être très très fort et d'ailleurs
c'est à une partie du jeu américain
s'est éventuellement de remettre
l'europe sous dépendance du gaz taux
américains plutôt que du gaz
il faut aussi avoir conscience que
derrière tout ça vous avez des éléments
de politique intérieure il ya des gens
qui sont un petit peu va-t-en guerre aux
états unis parce que vous avez des
élections de mi mandat qui arrive et un
certain nombre de personnes
souhaiteraient peut-être poussé by donne
à un conflit armé ou à une escalade
parce que ça permettrait d'avoir des
répercussions de politique intérieure
aux états unis de la même manière ont
aussi vous avez des élections de mémoire
dans deux ans a également donc
vladimir poutine il est aussi confronté
à sa propre opinion publique à sa propre
situation économique donc vous avez des
éléments qui sont dans la d'explication
qui ne sont pas forcément des éléments
purement de relations ukraino russe ou
bien de problématiques et un vis-à-vis
de l'otan est là dessus à
valérie pécresse elle a une vision très
gaullienne des choses très gaulliste des
choses c'est une position d'équilibré ce
que je vous ai dit disais tout à l'heure
nous sommes les alliés les amis des
américains depuis la création des états
unis avec des hauts et des bas mais nous
avons toujours été amis et nous le
resterons toujours et de la même manière
avec la russie nous avons une relation
particulière qu'il faut
mais une relation qu'il faut
reconstruire hacker qui a été laissé un
petit peu à l'abandon alors au début de
son mandat emmanuel macron avait fait
des choses intéressantes
le dialogue de trianon etc et puis tout
ça en fait est tombé un petit peu en
désuétude n'a pas été retravaillé et
toute l'idée de valérie pécresse et
notamment de proposer une conférence de
sécurité en europe avec les pays
européens et la russie ah parce que nous
sommes sur le même continent et ce qui
était dit tout à l'heure c'est que
l'europe est en première ligne se le
disait françois pupponi près justement
en cas de conflit armé ceux qui sont en
première ligne ce ne sont pas les
américains ce sont les européens changer
le paradigme sécurité autant
sur l'europe l'otan a son rôle à jouer
cet historique et ça fait partie de
l'alliance militaire de notre sécurité
en europe en revanche
rétablir un dialogue tendre la main vers
la russie et à mettre en place des
grandes coopération travailler sur le
culturel etc on ne sort de l' escalade
contre faisons de la désescalade et en
trouvant des moyens d'abord de discuter
et effectivement de voir ce que les rues
sont à nous dire aussi parce qu'il faut
savoir les écouter il faut pas
simplement dire où c'est un méchant ours
russes on ne veut pas lui parler non il
faut dialoguer avec la russie il faut
coopérer aussi avec la russie et est
pile il ne faut pas oublier que nous ne
sommes plus dans un monde bipolaire nous
sommes dans un monde multipolaire et des
états unis d'un côté vous avez la russie
qui est un grand pays et qui est de plus
en plus autonome économiquement il faut
pas croire que la russie dans ce sens
économique catastrophique le taux
d'endettement de la russie ça à peu près
20% les réserves de change c'est plus de
640 milliards de dollars a failli la
russie dont une très bonne situation et
vous avez la chine de l'autre côté et
des relations entre la russie et la
chine sur lesquels il faut que nous
ayons un oeil parce que l'europe est là
c'est pas simplement que la france mais
l'europe est en train de se faire
marginaliser complètement dont le
concert des nations et là-dessus la
france a un rôle à jouer un rôle moteur
je vais fait puisque le faire-part
d'animations liées parce qu'il est loin
françois pupponi désolé on ne vous
oublie pas justement sur la chine je
vous propose d'écouter parce qu'à
certaines voix qui porte plus que
d'autres manifestement dont on parle en
tout cas écoutez les propos de
l'écrivain bernard henri lévy concernant
cette crise ukrainienne était sur la
chaîne fox news
si vladimir poutine décident d'envahir
ce sera une guerre vraiment sanglante et
sale les ukrainiens aujourd'hui sont
aptes à se battre apte à se défendre
j'ai vu leurs tranchées j'ai vu leurs
armes ils n'ont pas les moyens de
vaincre mais ils ont de quoi se défendre
eux mêmes nous vivrons dans un autre
monde dominé par les chinois dominé par
les russes si nous voulons la paix nous
devons accepter la guerre froide
françois pupponi si nous voulons la paix
nous devons accepter la guerre froide à
3 réactions
pas dit comme ça mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il faut écouter les ruses
et je pense que la crise que nous avons
connue des dernières haut karabagh la
crise nous coller sur jeudi en ukraine
peut il doit permettre à l'europe et à
la france de reprendre le dialogue avec
la russie je crois bien que entre les
américains et les russes est extrêmement
compliqué et on a loupé son rôle à jouer
et c'est peut-être le moment est venu
pour dire on va dire arrêter parce que
effectivement l'un des gars comme moi
on a vécu les dernières une guerre d'un
nouveau type le haut karabakh avec
effectivement les drones la situation
était catastrophique des milliers de
jeunes soldats sont fait tuer avec une
guerre qui n'est plus conventionnel donc
c'est extrêmement rapide extrêmement
meurtriers avec des nouvelles
technologies ça sera effectivement sans
gants et on ne peut pas s'y résoudre
donc effectivement je pense que
maintenant il faut accepter quelque part
que
la zone d'influencé de la russie soit ce
qu'elle est quittant discuter après il
faut que l'otan arrête et peut être de
se développer d'ici d'avancé non parce
que là on est dans une guerre qui est
aujourd'hui une guerre froide météo fans
seraient joués de plus en plus et
sincèrement moi je pense comme la diva
norick ce sera extrêmement sanglante
donc le moment est venu que nous jouions
notre partition d'europe la france joue
ce rôle si nous y arrivons nous aurons
retrouvé une place importante sur la ste
angèle si nous n'y arrivons pas nous
serons les ukrainiens d'abord mais nous
ensuite les victimes collatérales de ce
conflit parce que bien entendu ça dérape
rade partout il faut pas oublier que les
russes sont aussi dans une situation où
on est est partout qu'ils sont obligés
de mettre des peuples partout et la
vraie question que se posent les
américains je pense d'une manière un peu
à peu pervers essaie de pousser la
résistance 3 jusqu'à où ils tiendront
jusqu'à quand ils tiendront avec autant
de trous impliquer un peu partout pour
sécuriser présent vidées et c'est ça qui
est en train de se passer donc y'a un
moment il faut qu'on arrête la
surenchère et je vous voyais là j aux
propos de bernard henri lévy qui avait
l'air de vous non c'est pas ça c'est les
propos de ben y'a pas que lui qui est
qui est actif qui utilisent cette
rhétorique aujourd'hui on a parlé des
médias américains tout à l'heure non moi
je je je je suis navré quand j'entends
ce genre de discours parce que moi ça
fait 20 ans que je couvre les conflits
dans le monde entier l'irak la syrie que
mon le mali la libye en particulier et
je vois une chose c'est qu'à chaque fois
7 cette rhétorique existe elle elle et
elle est avancée par des intellectuels
bien pensants qui pensent que d'aller à
la guerre ça va solutionner les choses
je prend exactement
à des fins la période de 20 ans puisque
les talibans viennent de reprendre le
pouvoir vingt ans après en avoir été
chassés et la première de ces guerres de
ce type ça a été larguée nice temps on
se rend compte finalement donc
l'afghanistan on y est allé pour vingt
ans plus tard redonner les clés à ce que
on avait chassé l'irak on a détruit
l'irak avec ce qu'a dit fort justement
le l'ambassadeur russe à l'onu des
mensonges ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui des
mensonges ceux qui ont proféré qui ont
utilisé
ces mensonges en particulier georges
bush colin powell lui même donald
rumsfeld maintenant ils n'ont jamais été
inquiétés par la justice c'est quand
même une guerre qui a foutu en l'air le
moyen orient et qui a laissé un pays
l'irak que je connais très bien en
lambeaux jeu je parle aussi de la vie be
ou là ce n'est pas des mensonges mais ça
a été une résolution de l'onu qui savait
qui était la résolution 1973 qui a qui
avait pour but de protéger les
populations civiles on est allé jusqu'à
la chute de kadhafi le même kadhafi dont
on s'est contenté pendant trente ans
sans que cela ne pose de problème donc
tout à coup cette rhétorique qui dit
attention si on n'intervient pas c'est
une catastrophe
et en plus entendre parler de paix en
temps de dire oui ça va amener la paix
le risque que ce que ça veux que vous
savez ce qui va se passer si elle une
guerre il va se passer c'est l'ukraine
va être le champ de bataille et en
ukraine ni les séparatistes de l'est ni
les ukrainiens n'ont envie de voir cette
guerre je regardais aujourd'hui des
témoignages justement à des confrères de
cnn d'une femme qui vit côté ukrainien
très proche de la ligne de front et dit
déjà la guerre de 2014 a été la pire
chose qui m'est arrivé dans ma vie donc
il ya des gens qui sont sur place s'ils
vont payer les conséquences de cette
intervention il y aura pas de vainqueur
la russie va pas être des fêtes et
l'ukraine si les départs l'otan va se
maintenir donc il va y avoir une
situation épouvantable avec une
catastrophe et comment voulez-vous que
eu la paix sorte de ça puisque les
quatre derniers conflits que j'ai
précédemment cités ont terminé par les
cds pays absolument anéanti jeu j'ai
oublié de dire pour la libye qu'une des
conséquences de la libye c'est ce qui se
passe au menu aujourd'hui également donc
attention aussi aux guerres qui ont des
effets de ricochet on ne s'interroge
jamais sur ces guerres là on laisse
passer et la fois deux suivants et bien
on entend toujours cette petite musique
de il faut intervenir à tout prix sinon
cela plaît du monde merci beaucoup régis
le sommier merci messieurs françois
pupponi charles pas d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france